[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to the lobby
GameSpot's weekly video game hangout
it's Wednesday the day before
Thanksgiving weekend here in the US but
we figured we give you one more episode
before get a few days off here in the
country I'm Mike McCarty your host here
with Peter Brown hello here with Rob
Hanley other great guy the shirt that's
a very vague reference to the joke there
they're wearing the same shirt it looks
like yeah and Kelly plaguey who has a
dope portable the man shirt on which I
really like them we've got a pretty full
show today
got a few news items to get through and
then this is kind of a year in review
2017 looking back on it at least from
our four perspective as the lobby crew
throughout the year and also like what
games did post release well in the wake
of some battlefront to stuff recently
and other games were kind of taking the
lootcrate route especially cuz I do you
see like there's more news coming out of
Belgium's doing that investigation again
it's Hawaii wants to investigate loot
crate's now yep yeah and then we're yeah
like in general we're gonna look toward
our most anticipated games 2018 but as
usual I'm the twitch chat I'm in the
YouTube chat and I got a bunch of
questions and comments and replies in
Twitter before the show went live so got
a lot to cover today first I wanna get
to some news things last weekend we did
our extra life charity stream and it
went really well we went for 72 hours
between the us office here in San
Francisco one of the US offices and then
London and Sydney and we raised 15
thousand four hundred eighty dollars so
we beat our goal by four hundred eighty
dollars thank you so much to everybody
who joined and donated it was really fun
craft Punk showed up here an Eric Andre
fan I thought he was discussing a long
time ago I don't know how he's free he
broke out so he was he really yeah I ate
some disgusting stuff we all played some
fun games you guys were taking shots of
that really hot whiskey vodka
he wasn't whiskey vodka it wasn't that
bad it wasn't that bad I don't know how
much you guys drank then because people
that's probably they tried to bring it I
was like can you bring in milk and he
brought in condensed like powder no he
meant milk yeah I know I was like are
you joking do you wanna know why that's
all he had is because
brought the creamer in the night before
when we were taking those shots to try
to cool it you drinking creamer yeah
yeah I drink I actually drink creamer
also I beat Ben Jenkin Mario credit
casually it wasn't that the result
during our tournament or he bu he beat
me
you guys gotta do some pickup game you
know it was casual
Nick was wearing a sombrero a little
thing you can't still donate if you have
a few dollars to spare at tinyurl.com
/gs extra life 2017 it's in the twitch
chat right now otherwise we still have
our page if you search on GameSpot
through Google and you can go find that
but otherwise thank you to everybody who
did join and helped out we crushed our
goal I see goob in the twitch chat he
sent us a really nice bottle of scotch
yeah he's always here a big supporter of
GameSpot
my mom was in the chat at one point yeah
my mom made you say something very
embarrassing oh and I never got the
chance to take it back so so stipulation
was that Kathy plaguey Kelly's mom I had
to look in the camera and say that
banjo-kazooie is a far better game than
banjo tooie and I wasn't allowed to take
it back for 24 hours so here I am
that's where she texted me beforehand
yes like how much should i donate to
make this happen I settled for $70 and
she just did 100 anyway because she knew
how painful it was for me but I take it
back - he's better than Kazumi in every
way I'm trying to get Kathy to come on
the lobby's we can actually debate it
live one day she seems to not want it
one day um cool yeah but actually life
went really well is a fun weekend we
wrapped it up in Australia Justin Dan
crowd got the $15,000 goal when they
were kind of half awake and pirates the
dancing yeah game fair weird and then in
other news I guess around GameSpot we'll
have a lot of Black Friday stuff going
up I figured this was a helpful to call
out we're gonna have like 4k TV guides
or anything or I mean we have gift
guides and stuff for Black Friday sales
I know there's a like computer monitor
Black Friday Guide going around but 4k
TVs now's the time to buy okay Frank Lee
honestly but do your research cuz
especially if you care about gaming on
them as I'm sure you people do yeah it
can get very confusing and you might end
up with a set it has something you don't
want cool so yeah so stay tuned and
GameSpot throughout the week and
like follow us on Twitter if you don't
and we'll have a lot of black fighter
deals going up and cyber monday I would
presume
Rainbow six siege operation white noise
Aaron got the chance to check it out
I've been playing a lot more Rainbow six
siege recently will actually bring this
game up again later in the show because
we're talking about games that do post
release support well and they just
announced a third full year of content
so this came out December 2015 and they
tripled their player base by the
beginning of this summer they doubled
rain so yeah you look around at games
like lawbreakers or even like destiny to
had a big drop-off and then the Rainbow
six siege they we want to look back and
like what they were doing I've been
looking at this live a feature coming up
and they just announced three new
operators if you actually play the game
there's Sophia who is the sister to Ella
right there on the dead one on the
ground right there they're part of the
Polish spec ops battalion forget what
the grant Grom I don't know if that
acronym actually means dope heavy and
vigil who are the 7 or 7th battalion who
are from the South Korea and that's the
new map is the tower in South Korea if
you want to look at more Aaron did a
pretty good breakdown of it and the
three operators but for those who don't
know this game is kind of if you took
overwatch and made it more hardcore I'd
say and tactical so it's all closed
quarters combats Rainbow six it's a
mostly indoor for the most part of the
Tom Clancy titles it's more CQB oriented
but each of the operators are like
heroes they have specific weapons and
gadgets and there's a kind of like
backstory to who knows who and who
trained with who and what not but it's a
there is a steep learning curve but you
can play casual enough I know Jake plays
it a lot Erin plays it a lot Ryan
Schubert here plays a lot this game is
fantastic and I they hit 20 million
players and they were they were
approaching I forget how many was
concurrent but yeah they just announced
a whole full third year they're in
season five operation white noise will
be season five I believe of year two
then they're gonna they set their aiming
for a hundred operators total there's
something like thirty now I think yeah
who knows but it's feels pretty balanced
throughout the time but I mean like go
this might be the time to get into it go
check it out fantastic game that
phone-hacking Edition seems really funny
that's uh doc cabbie I think I like the
app it's cute yeah you like because
credit correct me if I'm wrong but like
you can hack everyone's phone so that it
just constantly buzzes giving away your
position yes so like in order to make it
stop you have to open it up yeah so she
has two things a she can hack okay so if
you're playing the game is all about
attacking and defending so if you're
playing defense you control the security
cameras around the inside and off the
offenders can break those or whatever
and then the offense uses these drones
that you pilot in the in the prep phase
while the defenders are like fortifying
walls and setting up barricades and you
use those drones for your kind of eyes
inside she can hack the cameras and use
them against defense and yeah if you're
like kind of on the other side of a wall
from someone you don't know where they
are
she can do something to it like will
hack their phone it'll ring and so you
can see here where they are if they're
not moving the sound design in this game
is unparalleled I mean there's one hero
who doesn't make footstep sounds and
that's huge because this game if you
just stand still you can hear where
someone's coming from it's it's unreal
you should play Rainbow six siege I know
like I said Aaron has a lot more on that
if you want to get into it in will go
back to Rainbow six siege but in news
where I guess like bad post really
support news or not even host release
the day before battlefront to officially
came out they hours before yeah like six
hours three hours before I think is what
if you're saying when they pull the
micro trance yeah so they pulled the
ability to buy crystals which were the
real world money equivalents or not
equivalents but you buy those with real
money it's the it's the add the paid
currency in order to get and we've
talked about this extensively and you
know this this is good I'm glad that
they appear to be listening they did say
that they'll be coming back at some
point most likely in fact I don't even
think they said that I think they
decided no they and I I don't know I do
want to say really quickly there's also
the Disney element to this I don't know
how much of it was community feedback
and how much of it was Star Wars as a
brand so there's that to take into
account as well talking to eh saying
like what are you doing with our copies
yeah I mean I didn't I feel like our
story had information about like Disney
execs being like hey what's this work
yeah I mean if you Jimmy tells me this
is messed up
don't make jimmy upset my song yeah just
breaking out there's also the I mean it
was in mainstream press so there's that
factor but it is it is it's definitely
interesting that they they pulled
microtransactions after so much negative
feedback it's interesting and from what
I hear I don't play a lot of game where
people are telling me I feel like I
sound like Donald Trump very good game
but very flawed millions and millions of
Krista's actually has made the game
worse because it's stripped away this
thing that was part and parcel of how
upgrades worked how you bought things
and there's no viable alternative other
than grinding your ass off for dozens if
not upwards of like 100 hours or more oh
so it's made the problem worse some
rough estimate was like in order to
unlock everything naturally in the game
it's over 4000 hours I'm gonna die
before that so yeah yeah Peter you're
totally on point like yeah it's it's
it's cool that they they made a pretty
aggressive move but nothing has changed
it's the exact same progression system
so you're still funneled into opening
crates every step of the way like it the
changes that I and yeah we have talked
about this to death but the changes that
I would feasibly think that they should
implement are like the ability and they
had said this before originally when the
one the when the lootcrate system was
announced they're like with duplicates
you get crafting parts crappy parts are
the only thing in that game that allow
actual progression of your own and then
they will dis manual I am I am looking
at because everything's star cards right
so I'm looking at my class I'm like I
want to upgrade this I want to get this
card crafting parts allow you to do that
they took that out in for dupes its
credits now and I was looking at early
early footage of the campaign where one
things in campaign is you know there are
milestones for completing the campaign
and as well as finding the
doubles in this early footage there I
didn't like goes up to one of these
collectibles which now gives you credits
but in this footage it was crafting
parts and they pulled that as well so
the the point of pulling all those
crafting parts is just to lengthen the
amount of time and more of a bit of a
chance right yeah opposed to ya have a
major problem that's the problem is like
you should be able to look at anything
that game okay how much time do I need
to do this and it's just downright
impossible to gauge any sort of timeline
other than what I said earlier like for
over 4,000 hours hopefully maybe related
news Belgium that investigation into
whether luke rates are gambling is
ongoing there was like a report this
morning people thought that they had
reached that decision but it was
actually just the description for the
investigation saying the combination of
real-world money and chance and these
loot crate's is essentially a game of
chance and then I guess Hawaii is
pursuing that investigation now all
senators spoke out about it I mean yeah
I don't I don't know if it's so much an
investigation I think it's literally
like motions trying to do something
about it that Senator probably got a few
dupes most pissed off yeah I think did
it go it might not have gone up yet
Alessandro's it's kind of explained it's
going up today so if you are not tired
of hearing about battlefronts whose
problems yet we do have something going
up in games about later Alessandra on
our editorial team essentially just like
went through the whole timeline of what
happened and why you should care about
it what did my mean for future games
really good and very in-depth we want to
talk about too much today good but yeah
you can go check that out probably later
today on GameSpot before we get into the
bigger segments we want to talk skyrim
switch and skyrim VR and then we also
want to talk about games again like
Rainbow six they're doing post release
really well as opposed to battlefront 2
despite the fact that we haven't even
really got too much too long into its
tenure and then we want to look back on
2017 in general maybe give it no overall
review good the goods and Bad's and then
anticipated games up next year but first
we drove an LA noire switch review of on
GameSpot did you get them a chance to
play much of it no unfortunately not yet
I'm still busting my hump getting
through Xenoblade mm yeah we're starting
to see a lot of ports come to switch
this being the latest one and we've got
a full review up sounds like a lot of
the things kind of you know that made
this game stand out back in the day are
are still here it's been a few
compromises for switch they changed a
few things around to you know for all
the details check out our review I might
have Spinelli did it pretty good
write-up on all that cool yeah might as
well get right into it
Kelly you've been playing Skyrim on
switch yes last week for extra life
started in on extra life I don't know if
we know it also came out in VR I know
Joe who's been playing a lot of that I
got to check it out a little bit yeah
two more versions of Skyrim doesn't seem
like too many people are complaining I'm
sure it'll keep selling so Skyrim and VR
sorry switch you played switch yeah
Skyrim on switch is this worth getting
returning to we talked about it a little
bit last time but seems like almost an
ideal situation because I Skyrim the
complete edition what was it called last
year remember special at the special
edition when it came out I mean it was
it was great to have and I love playing
on PC with mods and everything but
switch actually seems like a different
experience just it can be handheld and
let's keep value in the question this is
a $60 $80 game for a game you've
probably bought already in 2011 yeah six
year old game I will say of I know we
talked about doom switch two weeks ago
now and how there were problems with
that port I think this is one of the
best ports on switch available it's
really well done
obviously that's to be expected because
the game is so old now yeah I mean I
really love Skyrim and I I think because
I put so many hours into it it's really
actually nice to have it in a portable
sense like I can just pick up play I
know where I'm going I go through bleak
falls Barrow I know which enemies are
gonna pop out at which time like it's
I'm kind of just getting this comfort
experience and that's the value in the
switch version to me is like it's like
returning to an old friend like I just
there's a lot that I like about it and
it does run really well and it looks
gorgeous and I do think that the the
switch the unique Stefan switch is
integrated pre naturally I mean that's
just really like the amiibo stuff I was
actually useful items to me so I was
happy to have them and it was better at
Master Sword right the Master Sword the
Hylian Shield and the champions tunic
from breath of the wild and the tunic
was better armored than I had available
to me at the beginning of the game so I
was very happy to have it I'm assuming
they classify it as light armor and it's
light armor yeah the ameba integration I
feel like I'm a cus I'm thinking of
breath a wild as well is like those kind
of give you just they give you like a
kind of like early game advantages you
know I mean like eventually the that
that said equipment kind of gets how do
you say like out match returned yeah the
later you try to use it yeah I think
that if I had tried 50 hours in to use
the amiibo it would have I would have
been kind of like cool I guess but I do
like that it's nested under powers and
one thing that I actually did like that
I think I might be in the minority in in
as far as the GameSpot office goes is I
do like the gyro controls for the bow
and arrow I used that in breath of the
wild I talked about this last week I
think
and with splatoon and I think it
enhances the bow and arrow mechanics for
me at least and so I was happy to have
that as well
so it's you know it's like obviously
it's there's not much to say beyond I
mean I did do a review on it and also
like its its Skyrim it's everything that
you remember skyward to be they didn't
fix any old bugs there's no new bugs and
having that portability if that's
something that's really important to you
for me that's something that's pretty
important as far as this game goes I
guess then that is the biggest advantage
I'd say have they said anything about as
Microsoft's anything about enhancing the
backwards-compatibility version for Xbox
1x I'm just trying to think of what
other platforms could possibly come to
it yeah the other thing I did mention in
my review is like if you're used to
playing with mods I actually didn't use
that many mods when i played on pc which
is weird if you're used to mods like it
can be weird
to go back I think to to an era before
moths really possible that have moms on
switch oh sorry oh they're gonna see
someone else I guess it would be took
would be possible but you know there
would have to be a limit right right
like if you look at the special edition
that came out last year there was
certainly a limit as to how much you
could throw in there yeah
I was gonna say don't be surprised at
this eventually comes to mobile huh or
at least mobile mobile stores that could
feed into tablets as well as compare
down version or even that 2011 game
could just easily be ported oh dude you
look at like the Nvidia shield for
example I mean even the the switch
itself is running off a mobile chip so
it's not out of the question at all
pista more oft more hates all these
Skyrim releases it's only helping the
publisher itself doesn't have a I'm sure
like I wonder how the Skyrim switch /vr
sales especially switch will compare it
to like prey sells another game that's
been published I have to imagine it'll
be like comparable if not more more I am
what's the the price of Skyrim VR is
that just a that's a good question I'm
not positive well switch is $60 yeah you
do you feel like it was worth $60 like
if you play it if a lot of you mind has
new cover art if you played this I got
it digitally so I'd enjoy the pretty
cover art yeah I think I will say like
$60 is pretty steep for a game you can
get for not 62 for less than $60 on in
Skyrim just on the street it's like an
antique at your grandparents house at
this point so I mean like I just for me
it's like I own Skyrim on PC and on Xbox
I really don't think if I didn't get a
copy for purposes of the review I
wouldn't have paid $60 for a switch
version yeah everything I'm looking at
right now says VR is also 60 dang and
you gotta support this extra development
somehow that seems like a a real ballsy
price tag it does cuz do and it does I'm
hoping it feeds into other things like I
just hope like what if we got oblivion
remaster they look great
what was the original six maybe we could
finally leave sky er go to elsewhere
Marsh yeah literally anywhere else I
don't care
welcome to s well that's the home of the
Khajiit and then black mark is the
argonians yeah don't get me started
playa lizard wizard any last minute
comments on skyrim switch no John Luke
has some stuff going up for Skyrim VR
and it's pretty funny like if you have
psvr you can see these move controllers
the other thing this is what John Luke
just enjoys doing I think we've we put
up an article that's got their video
you're watching right now it's bet it up
top freelancer Justin Clark what a quick
cool feature on what it's like to
revisit this game not necessarily like a
little bit on the technical level but
mostly the experience of just really
being enveloped in the world in VR and
what that feels like
so if this goofy representation you know
on a 2d screen doesn't convince you that
VR makes sense or is worth it check out
that article see what he's got to say
and do your best to imagine actually
experiencing this in 3d in VR more games
could just take a page at a resonable
sevens book and just kind of maintain
the actual controls but implementing VR
in a way that doesn't just become the
entire experience that makes any sense
at all to read zero sevens great because
the controls are very intact from the
base game it's just looking and
everything is with the headset and
aiming and everything but it seems like
a PlayStation Move controller controls
are a little bit of a hurdle the coolest
thing for me and I haven't really
checked this out too much is the skill
screen is like all around you so if
you're looking at like alteration you
can turn around and look at two-handed
and it's like behind you and you're like
in space and there's constellations I
think that's cool that's cool for maybe
five minutes
is this like tunnel vision always there
I was like to ask now it's gotta be just
be the export settings like I don't know
VR is we
is happy to like gesture it could be
just when you're moving that the game
does that like we've been walking nailed
it
probably to just keep your senses
focused on where you're headed and not
things moving in your peripheral vision
just to combat nausea people are
laughing at I think this is John Luke's
game play him French kissing that horse
hey don't kink shame well was its
bestiality guess in two new versions if
you still want to play this game still a
good game Skyrim on switches sixty
dollars and is out as of last Friday was
it yes and Skyrim IVR is also out for
sixty dollars as of tuesday yesterday
right
there was this Friday as well Tuesday's
I don't know same day Skyrim VR was
November credible this is art all right
cool I want to play it on switch don't
know so much about they are but anyway
we apply my Rainbow six siege where you
tell my battlefront to games that are
attempting to nail that post release
thing and then you have destiny games
trying to be games of service visceral
shutdown according to EA because they
wanted to be a Star Wars game they're
making to be more of a games as service
we wanted to talk about which games have
done post release content right and
compare that to games such as
battlefront 2 that seemed to be
struggling to grasp that and games with
loot crate's let's start with loot
crate's because that's kind of where
what seems to have sparked all this I
don't want to go back as far as like
Mass Effect 3 with loot crate's because
that's the first one I can remember
which was also EA I'm gonna go back to
overwatch which seems to be the one that
really sparked the fire recently really
dude it right yeah yeah you can start
you could argue yeah you could argue
that's just been their fault but I mean
they're all aesthetic where's
battlefront is actual abilities and
whatnot obviously if you haven't played
overwatch you can get loot crate's which
just end up giving you new character
skins sprays victory poses emotes what
am I missing or just more gold to spend
on ones that you definitely want to get
so that's the one silver
here of several I guess it's not just
the one but you can actually buy
specific skins if you have enough gold
hmm this you know makes me always and
this is not really feeding into the
argument with any sort of definitive
stance but when you think about like
old-school RPGs or any games that would
reward you for going into battle against
you know enemies and stuff you would
pray to get that rare item dropped from
them they were essentially walking loot
crate's but there was like gameplay
involved in it so it didn't feel like
this layer like once removed just sort
of put you in a different mindset and
system and I think that is probably the
the biggest issue here where I think
people can look at overwatch and say
even though it's just cosmetic yeah like
it's still this randomized thing you
have to put in a lot of time and effort
for and pray that you get what you want
and that's why so many people like
Belgium and Hawaii and everyone are
saying this should be considered
gambling and should how many times but
it's not people so so many people in
places such as Belgium yeah running
governments such as those in governments
covered gubernatorial roles in Belgium
and Hawaii are saying it should be
considered gambling a lot of people are
already saying CD Projekt RED does it
really well with Witcher 3 blood and
wine specifically the DLC actually gave
you
Toussaint like this whole new reason to
explore much like Point Lookout and
fallout 3 if you're talking about new
Vegas like the Lonely Hearts stuff they
actually added these new areas and that
was all paid DLC but you pretty much
know what you were getting witcher 3
like again they gave you another like 50
hours in blood and wine if you really
want to spend all the time digging into
that people who seem to think CD Projekt
in general I know which are to head some
DLC as well like I said Rainbow six
siege does it really well although they
introduced loot crate's this year with
for aesthetic options which I'm kind of
bummed about because it can take so
renown is the you can I don't know if
it's snowing up on the screen right here
now renown is your actual currency in
the game and there are Rainbow six
credits which you could that's
real-world money those might as well be
crystals and those can be used to buy
certain uniforms or headgear or weapon
skins for different operators you might
see in the b-roll here some of these
weapons have crazy skins
they I don't really it's like one of the
small problems I have with the game I
guess it's kind of big and I mean the
loot crate's work much like we've been
having problems with you they're not
randomized is the only thing I would say
so it's not loot crate's in the sense
that you know there you don't know what
you're getting you do know what you're
getting but it still does take a while
to grind if you want to get all the
renown possible because when a new
operator a new operator group comes out
you can either if you don't have a
season pass which is like $30 a year and
you get renown bonuses or there's a few
yeah you get renown bonuses or and
you'll have access to the operators like
a week early or you'll have actually you
know you'll be able to play them before
everybody else it it doesn't actually
affect the game too much but again if
you want to actually get unlock these
operators they're not available from the
get-go they'll be like 25,000 renown and
that could take like 10 hours to get so
I don't know I'm worried about this game
going forward if you don't have a season
pass I mean I guess you could because it
consider that season pass like you paid
$30 for blood and wine The Witcher
expansion the season pass could be
considered that if you playing this game
a lot and you know like I don't know
where we're getting the point we're like
oh well it's all aesthetic so it's not
affecting the game but like at this
point is still this isn't randomized
loot crate's but it still does take a
while and it seems like they're
encouraging you to pay money for it yeah
I mean I don't I don't know I I think
for a game like a game that is that you
mostly play competitively like an
overwatch or Remo six I like for me with
overwatch though the whole fun of the
loot crate's
is I have these couple characters that I
really like there are my mains and I'm
striving to get cool skins for them
because I like playing them and that I
don't know I don't have a problem with
that because personally I'm not the kind
of person who would spend money on that
sort of like there's nothing that like
gives me an advantage just just like
something to work towards and I think
that's a tricky balance to strike I
don't really know where I'm going with
this but I'm not as upset about the I'm
not like the phrase loot crate or like a
loot box doesn't automatically bother me
because like Peter said like you're
hoping there's play
games where you're hoping for a good
drop or hoping to get something and it's
giving you a goal to work towards I kind
of what a lot of games do yeah cuz they
have alpha packs in Rainbow six now so
every time you win a match you have to
specifically any time you finish a match
multiplayer or terrorist hunt or
whatever you get an increase in
percentage which can go higher if you
have a season pass but you get an
increase in the chance to win a pack at
the end of a win you can only get packs
on a win so you win them and then you
open in it's like a rarity maybe it'll
be a weapon skin may be able to be a
headgear for castle or fur to chunka
those are operators not just random
words the chung-kai he's like known as
the the worst operator of the game he's
got this big turret people call him Lord
to chunka he I don't I don't like him
he but the Alpha packs actually you
don't know what you're getting in those
and you can buy those with real-world
money if you buy Rainbow six credits
first and then spend those on alpha
packs which kind of sucks cuz I I know
those weren't always in the game but are
those things that like I think the
difference I think kind of what I'm
getting at is like the difference
between something like that where you
could spend money if you're like trying
to get a specific thing you're looking
for versus battlefront where it seems
like everything is driving you to spend
money because the alternatives are so
shitty
like with overwatch like I don't feel
like like I don't think spending money
on a loot crate is necessarily like the
game forcing you to spend money at
someone being like I really hope I get a
mercy skin yeah but like it doesn't give
you an advantage there's no there's no
reason to spend money on that lootcrate
other than I want to get this cool
cosmetic item cuz I love this character
or I'm playing this game a lot I really
really enjoy it yeah and like I want
something to work towards because
eventually like if you hit a skill
ceiling or you only play you know kind
of casually with a group of friends and
not everybody's at the same skill level
it's like where do you go from there
well you can get these kind of like
stretch goals basically for playing the
game but there's nothing about that that
screams like we're trying to get you to
spend money it's just kind of like an
option if you're really passionate about
it versus the alternative is spending
four thousand hours playing a game of
course I'm not going to do that because
I could work for four thousand hours
driving lift and make money and like
[ __ ] it right like any time when you
have to
wrestle with the idea where you think
about it oh great you know you mean
we're like an example like us I mean so
you're saying for Rainbow six like to
get those operators you can get them
quicker right bye bye pain that's what
you were saying yeah if you have a
season pass okay and well and unlike any
operators say you were to get in the
game that you don't have any unlock you
must be using the recruit until you
unlock certain specific ones for attack
and certain for defend you would either
be able to spend those Rainbow six
credits or the renown what you earn
in-game and it takes a while with a
renowned in-game for not for the base 16
operators are having money there are but
with year one and year two operators
those all are like 25,000 renowned each
now which is a lot that's a battle take
you like I think it I played a full day
Sunday and I might have gotten like 6500
renoun and then hey I am infinity is
telling me you can't spend actual money
on the Alpha packs you can only spend
renown on the Alpha packs so then
anytime you want to actually buy
something randomized that's what the
in-game currency so you can't spend real
money on something random ice packs yeah
so that's not gonna be for gambling yes
equation presumably right right so
that's what another reason thank you hi
hey I am infinity that makes the game
not as predatory I would say yeah and it
also its aesthetics and I still don't
love it because there are there is a
randomized limit and I it does feel like
they make prolong the process to try to
get you to shortcut like a free-to-play
game might mmm-hmm what about something
like rocket League which plays both
sides of the discussion right yeah
because you can get gear by playing and
sometimes you'll get a but you get a
crate but of course you have to spend
money to open that crate so it's kind of
sucks because you do get some stuff but
then the game is basically dangling like
I'm not gonna give you the free thing
I'm gonna give you the thing that's
gonna cost you $1 to open it and then
when you open it you get something
random and that kind of sucks it does
but the thing is is that the you can't
do it in the game directly necessarily
but there are plenty of websites that
even psionics points to you for trading
items of players right where you
actually have the option to to give up
something you don't want to somebody
else for something you do want and
and chat or sure to let you know that
that's having the trade option is so
helpful yeah mining and and rocket
League at least does a couple of things
I think that's that's I guess you could
say tasteful which is like I think it's
if you get there's two things one is if
you don't like that system at all you
can turn it off and never see a crane
yeah and never be reminded and only just
be getting as you said like naturally
these items or I think this would be
like maybe a tactic with the game is you
can turn it off and then I believe check
back on it maybe like ten hours later
Stearman accrued so you can see how many
crates you got and then flip five if you
flip five of the same crate you get a
whatever higher tier item out of it so
you can you can do that with the crates
to crate itself no you can turn and
create five crates right the same type
of I'm sorry what yeah yeah because I
only knew that was a deal with
individual items that you've got from
crates I didn't realize you could
upgrade crates as well you might have
said this those have to be ranked
matches this all goes into play right
cuz I play casual I don't earn any
crates I guess I'm a casual that's and
that's that's a frustrating part is not
knowing when or how you get them like
you want to like you want to like link
it to like a good game or a good
performance but it's usually I put like
by chance two hours into rock league and
I'll get at least one crate yeah and
that's always my benchmark when I'm
playing like at homes like I'll play
until I get a crate it's usually it
feels like within the same amount of
time sometimes I'll get to like I'll get
one right away and it's like well that
was only two minutes I'm gonna keep
playing
yeah and that being said though the
trading and the I the idea of trading
back with items is not a pretty system
you it's not yeah you have told me like
you are unable to do certain things like
it's the upgrade thing that you were
talking about trading in items so I have
like the same type of the same grade yes
like oto take five of these same type
same item category and you can exchange
them well I've got eight items that
qualify but then the game like lets me
put those in the bucket then it goes oh
one of those items belongs to a series
that doesn't allow upgrades and it's
like then why did you let me put it in
there
which one is it I don't know you don't
that could improve right and actually
now I think about it to top that on is
you know when they first implement that
that system it was just they're just two
types of crates but now as a lot they're
announces now you're diluting right the
chance of getting five of the said you
have said crate which but is the rocket
League also does the other things that
we're discussing rather you know I think
well right like you can pay money
outright for specific cars yeah okay
cars are cosmetics they don't make a
huge difference I think there's like my
new differences now the handle but this
annex also releases a lot of free
content and they have this game has been
out for over two years now and we are
continually getting like new modes of
play which Haraka league that can make a
big difference like that it was a drop
shot is that the name of the one yeah we
don't play that that often but that is
really fun like we do play that that's
really cool and some people that might
be their favorite mode in the game they
do keep adding a lot so I think rocket
league is a very interesting like thing
that has a slice of every tactic that
we're discussing which is and yeah and
strange and that's what I think we all
like to think now I think most people
like who are familiar with what used to
be the case with like things like
battlefield 4 right is when you're
locking these maps and you're paired
with a friend who has those maps and you
don't and you can't progress with them
into the next match like that's a
problem rocket League I mean titanfall 2
was an example of that like I was gonna
say titanfall 2 is done stuff pretty
warm pretty really well yeah it's been
all free map updates and modes and it
took was monarch do you have to pay for
mom no no no using game stuff for
monarch the new Titan that released
three months ago I think at this point
but if you did want to get new skins
it's not crates it's pay $5 they litter
it'll be it won't be an in-game currency
it'll say pay $4.99 USD or whatever for
this Titan you know what you're getting
the entire time if you do want to
splurge and get a new skin for your
pilot or your Titan we'll have a cold
camouflage whatever you know what you're
getting yeah it's all cosmetic and it is
it's very straight forward which is nice
it's just like here's you know here's a
bundle for like $20 and get all the cool
news like skins or a weapon in a list
every single thing that you're getting
it yeah exactly and if you don't want
the bundle do you know what I just you
know I use one that's what I do a couple
times actually many times because I love
this game so like I will happily
purchase these cosmetics as we said
earlier like I love this game
I still love this game it's just I feel
like I'm helping that studio two-degree
like we're great passion for the game
rather than like feeling like ah the
exchange rate for time to money is too
steep I thought the game is holding
anything back from yeah you're not
paying money to mate you're not paying
real world money to hopefully get that
skin of that Titan that you're shooting
at because you want it you are paying
money to definitely have it the next
match you go in with scorch ready to
scorch scorch yeah and then it does
remind me of again Rainbow six none of
the extras there's no gambling aspects
the only time you open something that
you don't know what's gonna be inside
you can't spend real money on it it's
in-game stuff that you're yeah that it's
just it's just winning matches that
you're gonna unlock that just by
happenstance or you can spend renown if
you have like three hundred thousand
saved up if you play that game regularly
and it games like titanfall 2 and
Rainbow six are rewarding players that
play regularly you know like so many
games are trying to do games a service
and I wish they would look at titles
like these more often because you look
at and people everybody's mentioning
Team Fortress 2 was the first one to
have kind of spark blue crates and one
I've had that random weekly item drop
that went up to a time cap and there was
no guarantee you're always could you
would ever get anything you wanted but
then you look at something like path of
Exile if you guys played this too much
it's the Duncan crawler kind of like
Diablo s game but they've been adding
quests they've been adding just in
general new things to do
throughout its I forget when it came out
now like four years
yeah like almost four years ago now and
it's it's a good game it's more if
people who were kind of lamenting Diablo
3 as maybe too casual for people who
like Diablo 2 kind of path of Exile and
torchlight 2 but mainly path of Exile I
think was the more mainstream game that
kind of cap
a lot of the aspects that they wanted in
Diablo 3 and didn't get maybe but it's
uh they've been we just had that they
have a new update they just announced
recently and there's just whole new
areas kind of like Diablo 3 did but um I
was talking to Eric Tate other day and
he was watching I think a stream or
doing Diablo 3 but they do kanai's cube
and everything was probably the last big
update but most of them just been
smaller new areas and challenges for
adventure mode if you want to do that or
just kind of quality of life things but
path of Exile is also great if you play
that you probably know that they've been
supporting this game really well since
lost this listened to launch it looks
great yeah it's really good it's it's
it's a huge game if you want to get into
it now it's like yeah it's a it's
fantastic it's good I when I was on
editorial I used to do the preview stuff
for the updates we know an editorial no
more boy I know what about GTA 5 this
one's kind of a weird one yeah yeah yeah
like a hundred bucks on this new vehicle
played a lot of that online but
definitely dropped off and it's not
necessarily an example of a great post
release system but it's interesting cuz
I think some things are pretty neat like
highlights of like how they have done
stuff I think is just a super strong
community that they've like listened to
and and have taken advantage of as far
as like hey like this weekend it's like
double xp you know like consistently
like rewarding people who really do like
that online who keep returning returning
but and I I'm pretty sure this is the
case is that would like what you start
hearing with like some of the last
updates they've had is like just the
cost of some of these cars and so my god
and then yeah that's part of it too is
the cost of like there's one there's one
update where they added like that rocket
glider motorcycle
yeah there's you know explosive sniper
rifle rounds dope and who's this
but these these are expensive because
this is you know the the dollar currency
and you can get that char card and get
those things quicker but you know there
they're to three million in-game at the
conversion I can remember yeah how long
would like three million in-game dollars
take you to get oh really I mean when I
was playing it was tough it was a really
it was it would take you a while you'd
have to like play only you know there's
the grinding method stuff like well this
this mission like rewards you with like
you know the most money so you just
remember like playing this and just
consistently playing that said mission
over and over again because there's a
highest reward but you're still putting
a lot of time and there are no gambling
aspects right you know what you're
getting when you pay money real money
and GTA ores are you saying the opposite
I don't know it's and you you just you
literally buy the like the dirt bike
with jets on it you don't buy the actual
item per se you just get you you put
money into the currency so like yeah you
and then spending real-world money in
two dollars is was and ones earning game
money or you normally yeah okay but yeah
I mean people work I saw complaints
about this where was like this really
cool old 1980s Mustang looking thing is
like more expensive than the first
update of like a really awesome the one
of the first like high-end cars like if
you compare the two like how can I mean
inflation is I guess what it is over
time right like they just they push
those vehicles and those items like
farther and farther the way I think but
yeah I mean I don't know I think there
are things to look at GTA online that
are pretty great Kelly you like the
community I think is really strong Kelly
you're mentioning Pokemon also does like
regular free gifts semi-regulars yeah I
wanted to bring us something like in a
little bit of a different vein from like
shooters and and stuff like that just
because like there isn't content you can
pay for necessarily outside of just the
game that you get but they give regular
free gifts of items and rare Pokemon and
so one of the good things for this is
like for competitive players like that's
that's the community that needs to
continue to have activity like obviously
you can play pokemon by yourself
but for the competitive community to
thrive people need
to continue to play and there's a
circuit all year where people enter and
stuff like that and so last year or I
guess it was this year they gave out a
shiny top of cocoa which has a legendary
Pokemon that I caught and I didn't
there's like things you can do like soft
resetting to get the best version of
that Pokemon possible and it's a really
popular Pokemon in the competitive scene
and I had a really garbage one and they
gave out a like a competitively viable
like super perfect version for people
and it was almost like here like we know
that not a lot of you were caught up
like here's a way to catch up and kind
of like get back into this and it was
nice weird tangent for me when I see
that I was feeling like doesn't that
devalue the game like the point of
playing it to try to get these things
and devalue maybe the edge of
competition that one player has over
another so I would I would say that if
they were giving out like perfect stat
Pokemon that you could breed yourself
but there's only one opportunity in the
whole game to catch top to cocoa and
there's only one so if you catch it you
have to restart the entire game to get a
better one right or you have to soft
reset for hours and hours to get the one
that you want while you're at that
battle so for like in my case
sounds good convenience it's doing free
it's a convenience thing right but then
isn't everyone just roll into battle
with that same free type of cocoa no no
because this is like kind of it's like a
standard build and it's it's hard to
really explain without getting to in the
weeds but basically there's six stats
and you're only guaranteed to have three
perfect stats for a gift Pokemon like
that for a gift legendary Pokemon and so
screw you still restart the game if you
want to be a competitor yes so so you
get that gift and you can still like I
know people who when that gift was in
circulation did a bunch of soft
resetting to get the best one possible
and even then people were like this
isn't this is like the closest to
perfect I'll get so I there's still an
element of like if you want to get a
super super perfect one you still have
to put in that work but it's it's a way
to to get people caught up and it was
right at the end of the competitive
circuit for the year so I just I don't
know I brought up Pokemon because it's a
little bit of a different case of like
you can't pay money for a Pokemon like
that there's no way to be like oh I'll
pay five dollars
and all of my Pokemon eggs will hatch
faster and then all you know breeding
will be faster or whatever but I do
think that they do a good job of
continuing to support players by being
like hey it you might not have this item
or you might not have this rare Pokemon
here's this free gift for this period of
time and it still like because it's such
a there's a luck element and you also
have to know how to use that Pokemon in
battle I don't think it gives you too
much of an edge like you can't like go
into battle at that Pokemon not knowing
what you're doing and when so I think
they do a good job of keeping that fair
yeah it's all in all I mean between
Rainbow six siege Witcher 3 titanfall 2
path of Exile I don't think we have time
but I want to talk more about warframe
apparently people are saying that game
is really really good now that they've
like been continually updating it
throughout when that release three years
13 that apparently like that game's
fantastic now if I want to check it out
because people have been mentioning it
saying the team has been consistently
updating it if you want to it's like the
most popular game no one's talking about
yeah so hopefully I'll check that out
maybe over break I need something to
dive into but Rainbow six siege is also
been taking my attention but anyway and
then I poke him on GTA 5 online with
more games trying to do the games of
service thing you hope that they're
gonna look to the good examples in the
future rather than continue stuff that
will piss people off you know as an
interesting example I just thought of
was actually Wolfenstein - what are
those those things that keep rolling out
there are like the like short stories
yeah they're like extra yeah it's not
really deal so you don't pay for it
though they just like roll those out for
free yeah I think it's interesting
because it's basically the ones that
there's like three right now yeah
they're there one of each of the three
gameplay styles without spoiling it that
you have access to kind of halfway
through the game so it's kind of like
it's nice because it seems like they
don't have to put too much like
mechanical effort into it it's just an
opportunity to explore a different story
and maybe a gameplay style that you
didn't like if you didn't do stealth
like oh you can do the stealth girl's
route I think it's interesting it's kind
of capitalizing on hey maybe because you
make this choice halfway through the
game you might not if you're all the
kind of person you want
to replay but you want to experience
what like that one crazy like stilts
thing is yeah here's a thing and it's
like a pretty cool way of you know I
think so many single-player games have
that like quick drop-off right or once
you finish it you are gone but like
here's something that's like you're it's
almost like they're trying to fill in
the gap for whatever inevitable I would
imagine actual Wolfenstein 2 DLC there
will be yeah of course like just like
dropping off and like going silent and
like here's our deal see you like right
like your cuz there is even like a
counter in the main menu where it's like
oh yeah I'll give it a shot I'll put in
like 30 minutes 20 minutes like every
couple weeks and the cool thing about
that is like they put so much effort
into building this world that it's
almost for me sometimes when I play a
single-player game like that I feel kind
of bad about leaving or I put off
finishing it because I'm like I'm not
ready to leave the world even though the
story is concluded and so with that it's
kind of like oh this is a chance to
maybe explore the world we've built for
you know in a more condensed you know
kind of like spin-off style yeah yeah
like I said hopefully other games will
look to these better examples as we go
forward Battlefront - who knows when the
crystals will come back but they said
they are gonna be coming back probably
but I want to look back at 2017 as a
whole and then see what what we think of
the year so started off really good
terms of releases this year in general
was really good with releases to say the
least the video games him first yeah
first quarter resin was 7 neo Nier
automata gravity rush to Yakuza thank
you I was waiting for that yeah oh wait
aku zero zero kawaman was later in the
year right the remake and I believe ok
horizon zero dawn and then Zelda breath
is a wild and not we'll get to Mass
Effect yeah solid list yeah and then
something else like it's not a
resurgence Japanese game developers were
not like I don't think they had like a
long dry spell but I mean like a lot of
these first quarter games and throughout
the year Japanese developers have been
doing an awesome job you got the next
quarter started off with persona 5 which
was already out by Atlus bright over in
North America man what case neo amazing
original 7 awesome like horizon zero
dawn Zelda
good news although horizon was Japanese
right sorry I'm just saying in general
the first quarter no and you get get a
pretty good amount of variety with that
first quarter - we like Bobby like this
for probably the best first quarter ever
but because I mean there's something for
a lot of different kinds of players it's
not like it's not like previous like if
you think about like November for me
November meant a lot of shooters or it
used to this was like and so like even
if the shooters are good it's like
that's one genre this was like oh you
can play kind of this you know
action-adventure there's open world
games there's you know Yakuza which is
its own people right it lives in its own
world zero is a prequel to the entire
series yeah oh nice - if you like if
you're a from software fan and nothing
new is coming out from the knee of neo
which that's kind of being reductive
because like then mix up not team ninja
no ninja theory team ninja sorry ninja
theory is hell blade also newswise hell
blade sold in the first three weeks or
three months some three months it sold
500,000 copies yeah which is all of that
money with the charity yeah I'm sure
traffic which is that's awesome we could
talk more about that later cuz I want to
talk about Hell blade but yeah Cal
what's your point there's a lot of
variety and then we hit March 3rd not
only does all that breath of the wild
come out but Nintendo switch which I
would say Nintendo has had a banner year
in general Rob you and I mean we all
have played a lot of Zelda but we think
Rob especially in robbing Pete have
played a ton that we got battle the
champ ballad of the champions DLC coming
out very soon sometime in December I got
those amiibo at my desk but what can't
you say about this game probably the I
still I think it's the best open-world
game ever made it's my favorite Zelda
now quick
shortly before Majora's Mask forgot how
much I loved the core ox fantastic and
this just like kicked off a switch
obviously it was on the Wii U as well
but I think obviously we would agree
this switch is a better
Wii U which that yeah you mean the
switch prototype that yeah seriously man
I mean a lot of games like horizon also
horizon resident 7 and Zelda all have
DLC coming out in December you know like
good timing to reinvigorate for holiday
sales and
for just like Game of the Year stuff
they care about that but frozen wild has
announced at e3 that's out already
I just like I know a lot of people felt
like horizon got Eclipse by Zelda in a
lot of ways but I will say that like
they're not as comparable as at least I
know I thought they were in the combat I
love the combat so much and it still
stands out this year for me yeah I think
the comparisons began with the bow and
arrow stuff yeah and then really just
came down to ultimately like okay take
combat out of the equation horizon is
very much an old-school open-world game
right it's like one of the best examples
of that where Zelda comes around and
even though it has some elements from
games like Far Cry if you look at the
tower's it still uses an open world in a
very different way than any other games
before I'd have and it was just kind of
like here are two very recent examples
of two different types of open-world
games that also share some similarities
so let's let's talk about why they're
different I review both of these games I
would depending on the topic I would put
horizon zero dawn above Zelda in some
cases
I still think Zelda is the more
impactful game for me though narrative
is yeah a wonderful problem yeah yeah
and that was the case with me I played
this a little bit it didn't hook me
until very recently maybe two months ago
I picked it up again and I beat it and
everybody saying the narrative was great
and I finally got that when I played
through I haven't finished it and I
would say the narrative is is the tribal
stuff is not I'm not as crazy about it I
mean I've seen people say it has a great
name it narrative and I just wasn't
convinced but I got the combat so
excellent the thing is the the narrative
opens up when a voice starts to connect
to the machinations behind what has
become of the world yeah
which has very little to do with what
the tribes are actively doing on a daily
basis there's more to do with the past
yeah so when agents of the past begin to
show up that's when it's like oh yeah
yeah so maybe you haven't gotten there I
don't know and then March rolls around
aside from the switch and breath the
wild and we were kind of looking forward
to Mass Effect Andromeda
kind of a contentious title I'd say
there's a lot of people that will defend
it there's a lot of people who would say
it was a disappointment
Ubisoft sorry not Ubisoft Bioware
Montreal released it and it was there as
a studio their first game and obviously
they have a lot to live up to with the
Mass Effect trilogy one of the more
popular franchises in history
but it was buggy glitchy mess and then
yeah it didn't look great it was I
thought the writing was bad yeah bad
writing Bioware Montreal members merged
with EA motives soon after to work on
battlefront 2 and we can talk more about
some other Star Wars properties that
have been shifted around today but did
any of us beat this game
no no cuz I gave a fair shake I played
like 15 hours I think John Luke Wow and
I never yeah I think Sean Luke and Jake
did finished it I know I don't think
they were they had a new saddest party
on the Citadel I think they're trying to
talk to us over the PA we can thank you
I can't yes game was again how buggy it
was and it was it's unfortunate because
it was you know you I would have loved
to see Bioware Montreal do well but game
came out was kind of a disappointment
I'd say like on Twitter a lot of people
said this was one of the bigger
disappointments of the year and I
thought I would just would have been
like much more fun to explore the
Andromeda galaxy but from what I saw I
just didn't do much with it anyway April
persona 5 comes in North America which a
lot of us on staff can't say enough
about I love persona 5 that's that's the
most time I put into I mean outside of a
game words like Zelda that's the most
time I put into just a linear game just
doing I don't know how to explain like I
wasn't I wasn't just continually coming
back to us to explore the world oh
that's a great part of it I was actually
like wanted to see it through to the end
it took me 95 hours I think and know
this this game is I know Michael Haiyan
was playing this in tandem with persona
4 which is an odd way to do it whatever
he went like balls to the wall with
persona because of this game I think my
the thing I could didn't get very far
and percent of 5 to my chagrin but a lot
of that was like the things a lot of
that was the stress of like managing my
time and I think that's something that
this game is that's really cool about
like how you how do you use your time
wisely but for me I was like oh god I
got yeah well it's pretty good about
segmenting like what you can do yeah but
then you also start to hear these little
stories about how punishing it can be if
you go and like I'm prepared into a
there's there is like a major thing
that's kind of spoilery and me and Jenna
look we're talking about yesterday if
you haven't if you haven't been doing
this consistently it won't ruin the game
for you but it'll definitely really
wound the pacing I would say so will
hurt the game for you sorry I don't know
why I said that wound yeah I was yeah
this game is like everything the
soundtrack the presentation the actual I
think the writing is fantastic I don't
think the I love the dialogue I don't
think the voice acting is great the
English voice acting at least that yeah
sorry the voice acting is pretty good
but the pronunciation I guess of
Japanese that's part of it though
exactly so I guess I can't say the voice
acting is that great but in terms of the
inflection and everything they did a
good job the actual emotion behind it
yeah like how would you pronounce well I
don't know the Fox dude's name I don't
want to say his name to ruin it and see
it okay so what about like on instead of
taco machi they say to comma key ug
sakamoto no as a comma de anytime you
put too much emphasis in a Japanese word
you're doing it wrong cuz they don't do
that that's not a thing every syllable
yeah it's yeah we're cases were you
shortened something yeah they really you
could you can download the actual
Japanese voice acting a few months after
it came out maybe a month I forget it
was it was pretty soon but I did wait
until it was out yeah yeah this game is
fantastic otherwise in April is outlast
2 and then Mario Kart 8 good game seemed
unfair to well no no I was not much too
was way too linear for me and scripted
as opposed to the first one but this
game what this was a chance for a lot of
people who might not play Mario Kart 8
on Wii you to play it against it
my switch library it automatically
includes all of the deals what was
originally DLC in Mario Kart 8 on Wii U
so like the you know link as a racer and
you know the animal crossing track and
stuff like that but also they I think
one of the most notable things is they
completely revamped battle mode which
was one of the big complaints for Mario
Kart fans when it came out on Wii U
because it was like it was just battle
like a weird bastardized version of the
battle mode that you might remember from
like 64 on race tracks instead of like
actual arenas and they fixed that
completely so it really is a significant
update if you're not just a normal
eraser yeah so yeah really really good
option on the switch and then we head
into may Fire Emblem echos shadows of
Valencia a reimagining of an earlier
spinoff from the series I was never a
big farm fan this quickly made its way
into my favorite games of the year
I just Kali you have you started yet I
haven't yeah I'm about to start it on my
flight yeah nice Jake is a huge farm fan
I'd say one of the bigger the biggest
fireman fan in the office he was he's
been telling me to play because he knows
I like XCOM and they share the tactical
strategy he's been telling me to play
awakening fates for a long time I
finally I went back to get those I
haven't played them yet or I've played a
little bit more of awakening would you
say that this is a good option for like
an entry point to the studio since it is
it's based on an older game or I'm not
Peter shaking his head I'm shaking my
head because it's very different from
what the series is at the moment now
yeah I mean it's very different from
awakening tactics and the army building
instead of in it kind of strips away the
relationship building that was so
prominent in awakening and I don't know
much about fates yes I would say it
eased me under the series I don't know
if it would introduce me well this who's
gonna say it's sorry no please oh I just
gonna say like I think like like I said
with persona I I get easily overwhelmed
by things where I feel like I have to
make a lot of decisions that could
affect my old game and so with awakening
it's like relationships can lead to
children which you know people basically
breed for their armies and awakening in
faith and with this like you can focus
on just learning the strategy elements
and there are differences to newer Fire
Emblem games I forget there's some sort
there's like there's one mainly big
difference that I can't remember right
now because I feel like I had it mixed
up last time we talked about the 3d
dungeon exploration was limited to
fireman gaiden when that came out of the
Famicom way back in the day and is part
and parcel of this the other big feature
this has other emblems games don't have
is that you can rewind combat yes yeah
so that is sort of like a it's not just
like a feature built into the game it's
a thing you have to earn the ability to
do and do it as often as you would
please but that also you know that has
an impact for a series that also sort of
is famous for you know perma death all
know it also kind of treats permadeath
as an option more than anything yeah if
you run out of rewinds in a battle you'd
the perm death will kick in yeah
but yeah kind of begs the question is
that really permit us right yeah but I
love fire woman I'm really excited to
start this game yeah I hit one point
where I had to grind with Celicas army
outside of that I thought the pacing is
great I didn't love the dungeons but I
liked the characters they're very simple
they're super SEBI when you go back to
them later cuz you have to get through
them to change the class of characters
to get to some other statues they become
really annoying because the enemies will
it's it's like they'll respawn what's
nice about this game I think and then it
strips away the relationship stuff is
that it really just focuses in on the
actual conflict at hand
yeah it doesn't just sort of like set
that aside so you can do some cute
[ __ ] sorry I hate the relationship
stuff and fireball I think it ruins the
games did you like this one more love
doesn't exist more it's it's different I
enjoyed it a lot I also really liked
awakening fates kind of screwed with me
because it had so many different
versions in the story felt fractured and
conquest birth right and after birth I
think nice one
thank you and then also prey released in
May maybe justice - which is a great
theme as well but prey it was you know
continuing the legacy of immersive stems
from Arkane studios rap colantonio is
the creative director on this ricardo
bear helped on it
I told her I told him that Stoney no
it's not Raphael it's Raph colantonio
you like saying so much cuz it rolls off
the throat but unfortunately he did I
mean good for him cuz he you know he's
taking a step back from game development
for a while and June he stepped down
from Arkane studios after like 18 years
I believe they go back to dark messiah
of might and magic arcs fate Alice you
know the games that kind of played on
the Ultima Underworld and original thief
games that extend that looking-glass
origin systems legacy of immersive Sims
unfortunately this game didn't sell well
dishonored death the outsider came out
later in the year as well from Harvey's
side of her Lyon France Harvey Smith the
they were kind of a two-headed dog of
creative directors over there before
Raph step down and do his own thing
hopefully he's doing well I'm sure he is
but praise a fantastic game contentious
I'd say some people likes a lot more
than others but I love this game they
love this the more I think about I think
it's it's really up there for what my
favorite games in a year really love the
city amazing I want to replay it yeah a
lot me too
and then III rolled around I kind of
uneventful I'd say not there were
there's some stuff xbox Scorpio was
revealed as Xbox one excuse you come on
let's go we're Metroid boy we were
originally we were gonna talk about 2018
today but we can say that for later
episodes we are talking a lot more about
2017 which is fine
Xbox Scorpio was called Xbox one X
finally Phil Spencer took to the stage
to talk about
they talked also about original Xbox
games we're getting backwards
compatibility yeah support and this is
the Xbox one next year obviously we have
our review up this is in the public's
hands now if you pre-ordered or just
bought one and I'm sure they'll be
selling more of the holiday season but
that was the first time we actually knew
what it was gonna be called after
Scorpio know it's ports look at what
else Dragon Ball fighters
[Music]
[Applause]
Dragon Ball Z exclusive for switch Tony
ps4 as well yeah I don't know if they
said actually they were just kind of
like we don't have a lot to say but it
is happening to me the fact my man at
the Pokemon office we're working on
Pokemon but he was crying so um Metroid
Prime for ya that T's life Samus returns
during that like post yeah what the [ __ ]
is that it was like is that I don't know
if I was like is that it looks like a
Metroid game and PC yeah mercury and we
don't I don't think we talked we talked
about this game a lot I'm surprised like
people have been saying oh I want to do
games to come back like it was so under
the rain I think this game got the
attention deserved the problem is wanted
to remake - it's on 3d s3 wasn't made by
a Nintendo proper and I think because of
that people meet yeah not that they
write it off but that they don't
immediately gravitate towards it as this
is what we've been asking for yeah and
in so many ways it's not what people
were asking for but it does sort of
satisfy so many of the things that
Metroid used to that we haven't had a
chance to experience and advances you
know what the series does well in some
respects as well you love this game
after beating I like this game a hell of
a lot yeah I think it you know I was
never really one to get too wrapped up
in the story of Metroid because I always
found when the when they really tried to
focus on it in prime it was almost like
overwhelming there was so much digging
to hear they actually they just sort of
they tell it through these very passive
means but necessarily pass it but they
they give you glimpses through images
rather than trying to like inundate you
with tons of you know texts lore and
stuff like that so you got to learn a
lot about the chozo which is sort of the
race that is the realism is the reason
that Samus is the way she is is the
reason the galaxy is under the threats
that they're under and they're actually
sort of responsible for having to clean
it up and my proxies saying this is
doing their dirty work
that's just all super interesting but
then you also get this sort of action
element that too
I've never had before as well and a lot
of people find that to be I think a bit
off-putting and it does take a minute to
get used to but once he get used to it
samus feels more powerful than ever
she's not just a gun anymore or a
someone who can jump like she is someone
who can punch an alien in the face and
then and then shoot it to death yeah you
know it's it adds a little bit of
momentary tension and extra a bit of you
know powerful qualities to the character
yeah Kayla you mentioned Metroid Prime
for as well that was the bigger reveal
they just showed the floor during yeah
it's so weird that like they put a lot
of small teases in that and the press
conference eating proper and they hid
that in you know after almost an
afterthought sometime next year they
said yeah and obviously like it's kind
of dumb to be too excited about
something that we just saw this of
it's going to get delayed yeah but like
it's you know it's kind of like meantime
go play the original trilogy still holds
up really well even the first game is
just the first game is worth playing
I like corruption a lot yeah Echo's is
uh is it echoes am I saying that right
yeah echos my second one that goes a
second yeah echoes is tough because that
whole light and dark you're out of
recharge you gotta get in the light to
recharge it's a little more unforgiving
I [ __ ] love Metroid Prime know the
first one it is fun to revisit one and
two on Wii U or we to use the motion
controls which were not and the game
keep original releases that's actually
an interesting reason to revisit to I'd
say um then we also got Beyond Good and
Evil 2 yeah which top to my list of
games I couldn't care less about which
sounds like something super weird the
way they described it's like no man's
sky like if you pull it off that's great
but the way they were describing it just
sounds nothing like what people liked
about the original people seem excited
for it but I have to be jaded here is
that just because of the name exactly
look that great potentially did you guys
like the tone of this like yeah I was
like why and this pig makes me want to
die alright what the [ __ ] it's a pretty
interesting as aesthetical yeah though
it sort of reminds me of Star Wars in so
many ways just like an alternate sort of
like timeline
we're like Fifth Element
sure yeah any other way this is who
knows when this is gonna happen but
Michelle and sell was up on stage
talking about and what they want to do
is sound very ambitious like mine mm oh
and that's where I keep stuff yeah they
had that like didn't he like show off
the game in like some kind of build of
juming out and then that's last time we
forget about it
so we'll see what happens with this I
don't necessarily know that I'm excited
for it but yeah Metro Exodus which looks
really good they showed it the Microsoft
there was a time though obviously the
Microsoft press conference was what is
coming out for Xbox one exclusively what
the timed exclusive yeah not much but
Metro Exodus excusing fairly I thought
was gonna be a timed exclusive I think
she's coming out simultaneously on all
platforms up I'm like January right it's
a month and a half away is it that early
it's January or February yes I can't
wait replayed last the other boondocks
the 1733 and last light is 2018 right
now I could've sworn I saw something
yeah it's just 2018 right now forget
what I said
I was wrong I think they originally were
saying like first quarter maybe that'd
be awesome
I don't I for some reason I don't think
would be here but for a games I loved
the first two and the what would be a
trilogy they put out a VR game set in a
very aesthetically similar universe
wasn't it in like an Arctic base or am i
think it is something I know I believe
that that's correct yeah okay cool
what else did they show yeah last month
- they showed more of Mario plus Rabbids
Miyamoto came out with a gun kind of
heard Inklings of that game Kingdom
battle but then yeah they came up and I
even Miyamoto we're kind of being bros
up on stage talking about it it was
adorable
I'm still not sold on Rabbids I must say
I was not then and I still am not the
game is good yeah hate Rabbids they're
the minions of video yeah there were
similar minions same kind of jokes and
whatnot yeah all right moving on from e3
so July well I'll talk about it's too
much we already that July was when we
had those on this show we started
talking about this battlefront to pay to
win they know that battlefront yeah
Rob dude this doesn't look great so will
Brees passes but that's when it first
started off in the pay2win video it
suggests that there was pay to win it's
just really quickly say sorry about
crystals per second it's crazy to think
that like from e3 was like wow this game
looks pretty good look it's and then
like and you see the abilities and
everything it's just like straight
ability
there's no tier or grade on said ability
and then like a month later it's like
just oh no just the loot crate's and
then yeah like epic and yeah oh yeah
we've talked about yeah yep and then
like pretty much July switch outsold
Xbox ps4 I think this summer is when
would splatoon to toward the end of
spring summer
that's when kind of switched into a
really gained its momentum through
toward the end of the year it started
out selling the ps4 and aureate I was
told the ps4 in Japan over its first 26
or so weeks if you compare them
side-by-side the 26 weeks after launch
and then October rolls around or sorry
September destiny 2 releases the big
sequel Bundy's big sequel I think that
definitely had a better start in the
first destiny despite the fact we design
around here for for a good while yeah
people what people are saying you're
about to freak out about battlefront 2
yeah I'd say destiny 2 was in a better
spot at release than a destiny one just
by the fact that destiny one had the
mystery curiosity behind it October
rolls around and this is what kind of
the news starts getting dour October EA
closed visceral the studio known for
dead space and they were also working on
the Star Wars game with Amy Hennig that
used to be 1313 we didn't really know
what it was called after that and they
said the Star Wars game ea said the
start with game wasn't enough of games
of service essentially so visceral was
shut down and then they moved production
of game to the other studios and then we
saw later that EA bought respawn in
November hmm titanfall 3 was kind of a
bittersweet announcement we know
titanfall 3 is a thing but we also know
EA is publishing it so the question is
whether they'll learn from Battlefront 2
or whether there'll be a lot of
microtransaction they
do they have to learn they've even
applied they're learning to need for
speed payback a game that is already
half price even though it came out a
couple weeks ago sorry half price it's
already half price because it because it
had I mean it wasn't to begin with it
also had loot crate randomized [ __ ]
which was indicative of I think what
will now be known as a z' past hopefully
I hope so yeah unless they bring back
crystals subtly and everybody just
starts spending ton of money on them hmm
looks like you tied and dropped and then
a loot crate drops right behind it like
from it split like I'd pooped out of the
crate crate what if what if there was
one Titan you know they were scorches
all fire attacks know what attack you're
gonna use when you press the trigger and
you have to pay to shoot people back to
November before this so Xbox 1x released
to middling attention I'd say I don't
know the full sales yet but it came out
it looks great it seems like it's worth
the price it's it's a really cool
console honestly like Microsoft did a
fantastic job redesigning the the system
itself and it coincided with a
redesigned UI which i think is still not
quite there but it's but it's much
better yeah it's not there but it's such
an improvement over what was there right
and then as of November oh can I
interrupt you
cuphead cup it thank you - no question
there's a bunch of games are not
touching on us big milestones but Super
Nintendo classic released yeah would you
guys think of that it's great I played
it's more Mega Man X last weekend it is
very great I like that so much more than
his class but that just goes to bed did
you see I forget who told me but uh
Nintendo 64 manuals have shown up on
Nintendo's website oh really
there's support for that patent a few
months ago pre upping the trademark or
what I'm sure yeah you look at those
things and it's like and you look at the
track record from NES classic - Super
Nintendo classic that's like alright are
we getting get antenna 64 classic I
don't know why else they would put those
manuals up there unless those games are
coming to switch but I feel like that's
the wave race tournament that like oil
rig map was the best one of course but
our Marines Oh
no it's chameleon twist
gecko yeah we talked about pub he
reached no no you want talk about cop
had of course he just wanted to say the
name cup head side cop had finally
released after one five years and like
we're kind of worried like is this
really gonna live up to it I was great
house few games yeah fantastic my fair
games of the year I know Joe we would
echo that sentiment they sold a million
copies at least they sold much more now
many more now yes yeah so congrats to
CEO and bhr we got a whole
behind-the-scenes thing if you can I go
watch that go we did an awesome job on
it
as soon as your watch is working
different watch as of November pub G
sold 20 million copies which is huge
still early access until December unless
they delay it I played a bunch last
night oh yeah finally did time yeah
first real game we were number two for
the team but dose it was like in the
last five alive or the real cry myself
dope like it is fantastic um holy the
desert map comes out before the end of
the year but they said they're aiming to
bring it out before the end of the game
comes out yeah that's that's like part
and parcel of the one point notice yeah
and then they were closing on two
million concurrent players it's been
number one on Twitch for most of the
year I'd say so that player no one is
doing very well I already mentioned EA
bought respawn
I think November was when the well
obviously November as battlefront 2
approached its release date was when the
controversy reached such heights that EA
removed my cartoons that comes the day
before official release where to talk
about that remember that number that
episode the lobby we talked about that
in November few of them man yeah you
mean several episodes of you outside of
releases there's a bunch of games I can
get the chance to mention the woods
night in the woods fence I'm Mario and
Mario Assassin's Creed October 27th is a
huge day what was your favorite among
those Mario
when did agents of me yeah lawbreakers
good game but it didn't really maintain
a player base they should have put my
client as cliffy B yeah
I would say in general banner year for
Nintendo do we all agree on that
yes come back come back would you call
it come back don't call to come back
would you come back you said would you
yeah I I would I would it's always kind
of strange because it's like they've
been working in this stuff for years
it's not like they couldn't have maybe
done it sooner but it's certainly a year
filled with great things that you know
we've got our expectations and with what
are those expectations expectations were
set up for years of disappointment it's
tough to say but it's still very very
impressive games between Mario and Zelda
at least those two leaving out some of
the more recent bad news of studio
closings and predatory economic
practices would you say this was the
better one of the best years four
releases since the 90s or 2007 or 11
even more exciting years I'd say yeah
overall quality yeah you guys agree yeah
absolutely fantastic yeah especially
it's not just fantastic there weren't
that many disappointments you know and
there were a lot of surprises yeah
there's a lot I'm gonna be playing after
this year's over to feel like there's a
lot I'm gonna check out still yeah
people are saying new 'wipeys like
horizon uh so this I'll go through the
Twitter things quick before we all kind
of aside an arbitrary grade to this year
best the best I'll walk with three three
at five on Twitter sighs the new IP is
like horizon getting a lot of love by
critics and consumers and then the worst
part of the year was games at Service
motto being pushed by big publishers
people also a bunch of people Jesse
Radomski who we work with sometimes even
PR he was saying dead cells recently
sold 500,000 copies they're still in
early access they are and that was a
fantastic a fantastic game I don't know
what they're adding to that to finalize
it we've talked about this before but I
added a couple new locations in an
update I think a week ago or two weeks
ago the 15th I think was when I went out
that game and pub G are the sort of
games that get people enough people
talking where it's like crap how do we
think about early access games now yeah
it's a real tricky situation but it's
cool to see games get a shot
or at least a new venue for games to
live where they might not have been able
to you
aramis constant friend of the show
saying best again horizon zero dawn
exceeding expectations worst Monster
Hunter stories getting completely
overlooked due to lack of publicity and
releasing the same week as destiny -
plus plenty of other great games were
overlooked we didn't overlook that game
we tried it and it's not that good talk
to Justin who although I'm quoting him
DD Davis he met ok he mentioned a couple
things that I won't say cuz they were
actually spoilers for certain games this
year he goes best as III reveal of
horizons or at on frozen wild worst it
was no man's sky being a visceral Star
Wars game falling apart and then like 15
minutes later he goes wait was no man's
sky 26 still this year that good like
really good I went back to it it's like
it's better miles better yeah I got try
that out in warframe did you ever play a
no-mess guy at all 6 hours which is
nothing you you I think you thought it
was you liked I thought it was great but
I think I I don't know maybe I went in
not even caring about the game at all
and what I found was the path I followed
was not the one that most people wanted
to follow your expectations were not
that high based on a lot of that ish
that hate was was because of like these
promises that were so my expectations
was scale everyone else's expectation
was scale and quality of things no I
think it was the it it all came to a
head when you couldn't meet someone else
in the galaxy that was it people threw
their hands up and they were like [ __ ]
this game [ __ ] Sean Murray [ __ ] all
these lies is [ __ ] marketing yeah
that was one little thing that game has
some really fantastic stuff going on
especially from a narrative perspective
which who would have expected that from
that game most people have not played
through that narrative and they write it
off which it's like a metal gear solid 5
situation for me all over again
no one finished that game it everyone's
talk [ __ ] about dude come on right here
something speaking of
10 out of 10 this year SuperMario
Odyssey do we need the original sin'
legend of legend was Ella brought the
wild and divinity original sin to to a
lot of us at the office of fallen in
love with great kind of return to
computer RPGs or how about my isometric
kind of system John Luke and myself and
Jake and that game is fantastic I love
that game so much fantastic RPG and then
one more person Connor Allen on Twitter
says best the quiet opening a breath of
a while the entire aesthetic of persona
5 new docks cities festival hell blades
moving depiction of mental illness and
then worst no option to date uck and
force on a 5 and the sort of soulless
look of Secret of Mana remake the
relentless heterosexual ISM persona 5
relationships net game right don't think
so hmm seems weird cuz the whole game is
about is about setting yeah
society norms and it's yeah yeah and
then Lloyd chronic good girls though a
lot of cute girls every friend of the
show Brett was saying hearing for some
fives battle theme for the first time
was incredible I knew I was immediately
hooked same here Bret cool I think my
laptop just died but anyway I want to go
around quick you don't have to do an A
to F scallion off to do a one to one
hundred one to ten what would you rate
2017 Peter Brown sandwich out of meal
okay fine I don't know Z okay no it was
a great it was a freaking great year
four games out of an A to F whatever it
was easy and it easily an a well I
wouldn't say a plus can't say a it yeah
I feel very conflicted because there
were a lot of things outside of games
this year that stressed me out a lot and
I felt guilty about being like but games
are good right but like hey the struggle
continues it was just like a very
conflicted year but game saving games
games are a great way to escape imagine
imagine you get you get like an ice
cream sundae and then it's it's like
pretty damn good and then as you're
eating it you go oh oh [ __ ] your peanuts
in this are you allergic
oh I didn't ask for this and then it's
just like ingredient after ingredient
it's like there's Captain Crunch oh this
is crazy
that sounds good okay I'm really
confused about if that's good or bad I'm
crunching it's like next thing you know
it's like oh man this is one of the best
sundaes oh so the Year just got better
as it went on I know you're gonna say
those things ruined it like mine oh yeah
there's that larger metaphor at fighting
we know there is a cockroach him he's
like hollering so somehow this is just a
bad idea okay sweet I don't know I give
it a three plus I go b-plus show you -
show your work averaging Wow the
releases weren't a plausible reads gonna
do it release for an a-plus video game
news overall I'd say news news deuces
I'd say we're a collective c-plus so
that averages out to what like be sure
not I'm into this and then I'm giving it
less than an A - because I'm gonna be
contrarian so I'm gonna go b-plus
and anyway that's pretty much our show
aside from our giveaway coffee our
giveaway Kelly has got it over there
where it's one of those weeks where we
want to show you and you're not gonna
expect this the cameras gonna cut over
to her and you're gonna probably gasp I
saw it cuz I go yeah that's the case
this week is a a one-to-one replica of a
Gears of War Lancer complete with
bayonet can you uh kill that can you get
bubble wrap can you push it forward I
would say you can't take this off that's
illegal
ah and then pull it back yeah makes with
chainsaw noise as always do some Marcus
both as always follow GameSpot on
Twitter if you don't already
and then retweet our giveaway tweet and
go to our site for the giveaway and then
in a few days we will pick a random
winner and there you go that's a
giveaway for the week Thank You Shiva
and gas for setting that up and
everybody in the twitch and YouTube and
GameSpot chats and anybody who sent in
replies on Twitter we don't have an
episode next week because we are gonna
be busy with Game of the Year stuff
sorry the u.s. Thanksgiving break so we
might be back in two weeks I believe for
like a last episode of the year until
then
thank you as always for joining Eric
take John Luke and Richard in the back
thank you as always for producing the
show and we'll probably talk to you
before the end of the year but if you're
in the US have a great long weekend
catch up on some games get ready for our
game of the year chats if you're not the
US have a great rest of the week and a
good weekend do the same and we will see
you in a few weeks have a good one Boosh
banter
[Music]